[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
sorry
I'm Wade I'm Amber
[Music]
we are gathered here today to say
goodbye to [ __ ] boots
the boots you are done to your last life
made to retire
[Music]
oh brother cats sister kitties meet your
new roommate
well
I'm supposed to be a Fearless hero a
legend this is a person party that's
your party so this is where dignity
your Puss in Boots let's talk
I don't speak Spanish either you're
funny what's your what's worry my story
what are we looking at get up nine lives
watch watch watch
I think you said they have been too high
no I am on my last laugh oh no
legendary
wish waiting to be granted
I need your help is the great [ __ ]
boots asking for help well you see yeah
okay please that wish look at me my
life's back okay okay possum face I
won't make you back but first
hey slow down I know what I'm doing
what what what's funny nothing should be
funny
everyone is looking for a Wishing Star
I'm going to wish for everything to be
just right
[Music]
you will find your reward does not come
easily what's in Boots Goldie bears
[Music]
when you only have one life that's what
makes it special go get him tiger hey
take it easy
just gonna be fun
[Music]
is in the dark Forest we step through as
one ready one two after you wait what
dog
still alive let's go find out
this year marks the 100th anniversary of
our town finding the Bells how can those
be Santa's Bells when there's no such
thing as Santa of course there's really
a Santa right Mr Martin there will
always be non-believers but don't let
them rob you of your Christmas spirit
somebody stole the Bells
[Music]
are you going to cancel the ringing of
the Bell celebration absolutely not
Pleasant Bay represents the joy and
spirit of Christmas cheers found this in
the garage George bottoms wait a minute
my dad didn't do this Violet you're the
smartest person I know you have to help
us
means motive opportunity this is what my
dad does at work it's how he decides
impossible suspects we have to find
another person who has all three of
these things you don't seriously think
you can solve this case do you why not
for starters you still sleep with a
stuffed animal
these are our suspects
maybe I should make this curl the new
shower are you gonna need detective
stuff
I think I found some proof I think we're
done with this if there's anything I can
do to help with your bottoms shouldn't
we at least try this is getting good
no one is going to rest until the bells
are back where they belong
[Music]
with that I have a Christmas wish what
is it I want Mr Barnes to be home with
Kenny for Christmas we have to find out
where it goes I don't think that's a
great idea man up Kenny that's sexist
[Music]
whoa what kind of Airship is that I've
never seen anything like it baby clayed
what is the president doing in our front
yard our entire world is in grave danger
I want you to come with me on an
expedition
I'm not my father he was the Explorer I
know you were just a kid when you went
missing but now you're all we got Mr
Clay I'm a huge fan thank you [ __ ] your
dad do you think you could Forge his
autograph what
where in the world are we
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
we are clearly in Uncharted Territory
[Applause]
wow
hello you probably don't understand a
word I'm saying of course I understand
you dad dad Grandpa I'm a grandpa what
is this place the cliffs are alive and
the waters dissolve the flesh off your
bones everything down here is trying to
kill us
[Music]
do you mind if I call you splat you just
kind of give me Splat Vibes ow
I guess I deserve that
Grandpa's awesome he is not awesome you
gave me a machete for my birthday
I was too
I'm loving this family reunion but come
on we got a world to save
[Music]
you to figure this out otherwise we're
doomed we are doomed wait seriously no
I'm just messing with you
couldn't see that coming
[Music]
what was that that is an ambulance
that was a car tire
s
I have no idea what that was
New York City did we just move here if
we did you think Josh is gonna be okay
this is my crocodile why I take good
care of him
oh
gosh time to wake up come on
he's not dangerous he's Crocodile he's
just lonely like me hey you awake yet
you can't talk but you can sing at the
top of the world tonight
when no one ever
to hide
everybody get out of here there's a
crocodile in the house
okay
this could not be happening we have a
crocodile living in our attic
that was totally awesome
the city must do something
do you realize how different things have
been since I met him
changed everything for me
not just for me for YouTube
I've been shaking I love it when you go
crazy
we have to show people that they don't
have to be afraid
you got a crocodile on a motorcycle
I've been holding me back
I know that change can be scary but it
can also be exciting
[Applause]
let's start our new life
[Music]
thank you
Robert
does anyone in Andalusia ever just say
stuff not if we can help it
this world feels very different is it
sometimes easier to live in andalasia
well I wouldn't say easier we have
dragons and ogre rebellions last year
the entire kingdom was trapped in a
giant whale oh this is not a magic land
it is a land far far away from my
friends I'm so late I'm a commuter now
you're riding this train over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over and then you die
as you can see Giselle everyone has
their place once you've found where you
fit Monroeville can be whatever you wish
I wish for a fairy tale life
I'm happily ever after it's not always
that easy
like dresses
Jumping Jelly sticks we got magic
this town is turning into a fairy tale
but it's all gone terribly wrong on the
last stroke of midnight
nothing will be as it was before
an evil cat I'm not an evil cat I'm not
an evil cat what is going on you need to
remember your place here Mr mother
please
is it under a curse we have to stop this
or everything and Elation will die
there's no unwishing your wish now
Giselle come on time to be heroes you
know there's only boom one villain in
this town
you're hilarious
delusional but hilarious
oh life moves fast one day you're
playing Kick the Can with kids named
flick and Schwartz
the next thing you know you're a
certified adult
Ralph dear old man
he was the best
wealthy promise me we're gonna make this
a wonderful Christmas that would make
your father so happy I promise
what have I done and that was all up to
me I suggest you start drinking and
don't stop till New Year's
[Music]
it's this amazing incredible we will
meet you right here when you're done
don't let him kick in the face
honey it's not labor if we don't pay you
yeah
cheers
that doesn't mean it was easy
[Music]
[Applause]
that's brutal It's the Most Wonderful
Time
slowly I could feel the Christmas Amber
beginning to Glow again
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
me
heart of that world
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
that is but a taste of our Fury
do you yield
I do not
I finally found it now who's gonna stop
me
what is this place
do not touch that mushroom you'll die oh
I'm sorry that one's perfectly fine come
on Mario
Mushroom Kingdom Here We Come
[Music]
Egypt a land of mystery intriguing and
Rich history
[Music]
a world of mummies under the Earth
[Music]
a royal wedding ring
it's the man the man who took the ring
the only way to get it back is to go to
the world of the living
[Music]
wow
it's beautiful
[Music]
oh oh look we can use a human champions
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
I banish thee from Salem forever
[Music]
they were right to fear thee
magic has a way of uniting happy 16th
birthday child
I have a gift from my favorite customers
Legend has it it's on the 16th birthday
that a witch gets her powers
Gilbert where did you get that candle we
have to get out of here which it'll be
here any seconds the book is alive he
woke up
if we intend to live past Sunrise we
have to steer this so whoa whoa wait can
we talk about this no
leave
Not freak out if a mental Maniac
obsessed with getting revenge on Salem
so
[ __ ] for Salem
I should get some salt why so it tastes
better when they eat us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
okay time to go you can't leave me and
Roger cologne together for a whole
weekend don't forget to unload the
dishwasher
I can teach you lots of things little
brothers I call it my rod Rick rolls
don't you mean roderick's rules Roderick
rule number one no apostrophes or any
other nerd stuff
[Applause]
[Music]
so what's rule number two you only get
one roll a week that's Roger rule number
two that's not fair rule number three
life's not fair and now you made me
break rule number two uh
roderick's been taking me under his wing
been teaching me a bunch of stuff what
kind of stuff
I've got potential
[Music]
attention
mean you're gonna have our battles
but when the chips are down don't let
him get away I'm gonna have your back
and you better have mine
you look like you wet yourself
the baby
it's nasty
girl number 10 always go out in a blaze
of glory Susan
oh you see I can't unsee that
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
I present to you
the eighth wonder of the world
[Music]
the one and only being
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
loose without a conscience can you
imagine the trouble he's gonna get into
wouldn't want that on my conscience
everybody who's anybody wants to be a
somebody that I want to be real why on
Earth would you want to be real when you
can be famous
hahaha
[Music]
okay we should have been home by now
he won't be a puppet anymore
that's for sure
[Music]
be brave
truthful
non-selfish
[Music]
you'll always be my real boy
a lie can really change a person pinocs
what's happening Jiminy looks like some
sort of fairy magic
kind of on the nose if you ask me
[Music]
I blamed bad luck for everything that's
gone wrong in my life
[Music]
sure have bad luck Sam Greenfield
take that universe
oh until
I found an actual Lucky Penny
something that could finally turn my
life around
[Music]
and what did I do
flushed it down the toilet
your flushed my panties in the toilet
you just talked
wait I just need another penny
[Music]
always with the obnoxiously long
password
foreign
the land of luck I'll leave as soon as
you give me another Lucky Penny you best
start blending in hello
Mighty leprechaun foil line well done
nature this is where good luck is born a
dragon she's the only creature that can
sniff out bad look there's bad luck here
too good luck on top bad luck on the
bottom the tiniest amount of bad luck
couldn't shut down our entire operation
just how unlucky are you oh oh no
super duper unlucky you cause a disaster
the good luck connection has been
severed
I do you and everyone else to a life of
bad luck we need to fix this
good luck to us both
what about Jeff
yes
I have no words
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh wait
yes sir
yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah
[Music]
sometimes real magic only occurs in the
Most Wonderful Time of the Year
oh Nutcracker when did life become so
complicated my old playthings I wish I
could be a kid again and to play with
you like I used to
did you hear that sounds like squeaking
that's what I call a fight Nutcracker
Marie
hey this used to be my home now it's a
nest for rest my son shall assume the
throne in place of this weekly let us
help you defeat them you want to help me
uh-huh
let's go we'll send those rats back to
the sewers they came from
there was an ancient magic loot I play
it and the Rats will turn back
let's go hunt down a flute prepare the
feast
[Music]
welcome
that I've ever seen before an enchanted
holiday Adventure miracles happen at
Christmas and Christmas Eve tonight
[Music]
I won't let you down father what are we
supposed to do
no matter what happens I will never
leave your side The Nutcracker and The
Magic Flute
any kind sir what no need to stare yes I
know it's nice
from the studio that brought you
Timeless Classics like a wonderful
winter of Mickey Mouse a wonderful
spring of Mickey Mouse and the wonderful
and you get the idea
Disney plus presents
unbelievable new special like you've
never seen before
fall is a special time of year
makes me happy
it's the perfect time for bobbing for
apples throwing corn in holes and don't
forget about maple syrup taste testing
I'll be going to take the syrup right
into the bottle for you
no and most importantly reconnecting
with family roots
house
or the fall is a great time to make a
new name for your family
[Music]
streaming November 18th
a new Mickey special
[Music]
that'll give everybody pumpkin to talk
about
that don't look good
it's a wonderful Autumn of Mickey Mouse
streaming November 18th
on Disney Plus
thank you
[Music]
she was a bad bad nevertheless
now baby I'm all right
every time I'm leaving on you you don't
make it easy
miles
you got a minute oh look
it's a long story is this the room you
grew up in uh it is but uh my my dorm
room is very adult right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
I missed you too okay
so what are you doing here I mean I
thought I'd never see you again
want to get out of here
[Music]
I
am rounded
bummer
what
is Spider-Man grounded
um
I mean I
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
fairy tales are all the same
the princess the hero but this story
is a little different
I am the amazing Maurice that cat can
talk well of course many of us have
right go go go
so what am I in your story
um you're not handsome enough to be the
love interest then you're not funny
enough for comic relief
um right I'm off to get my adventure
back
let's go
I think I love her
looks like a town with opportunities
it's all quiet
there aren't any local rats here it
smells doesn't it smells like a a
mystery there has to be a clue that
would Advance the plots a world doesn't
have a plot things just happen
are you all right yeah I'm all right
because I landed on my head
ominous
don't worry I can't always lands on its
feet
ah Maurice amazing Maurice you have to
fight it
[Music]
what you'll have to find out the rest
yourself the amazing Maurice
it's really not your average fairy tale
important safety tip don't need a dead
rat that just ate something that just
say something that made it dead
[Music]
are you ready get me down this second
you asked for it
all I want is a simple life they're
always unhappy I wanted you to wake up
from your slumber
[Music]
huh is that a baby Grizzly how did he
get here they're a good Mission it must
have been misdelivered I suggest that we
all helped no no don't say another word
live with this baby Grizzly
he's about to take flight
they're waiting on a stork to deliver a
baby to this grizzly fool someone needs
to feel the baby Zach will show them not
to mess with me how many of them are
there a bear is anyone hungry a Hair
Stop yelling at me it's bad for your
complexion a stork what's wrong can't
catch up
[Music]
with black spots under his eyes I am the
giant panda wizard
Charter course
that way
and slide into Adventure
featuring the voices of Pauly Shore hold
my bear and Jesse McCartney saving the
world always gives me a headache we're
going prepare for impact from now on I'm
flying first class follow me
I thought you wanted Adventure
special delivery
no no no no no it's just cold summer
and Jerry are back in an all-new holiday
movie
Touch of Magic from old smiley
there doesn't time to say my nose
Jerry's nephew Tuffy creates his very
own snow friend oh I'm much more than
that kid I'm here new bestest pal but
when the weather outside is frightful oh
it's getting warmer guys better find a
way to cool down it's up to Tuffy and
Jerry to save their new friend it's not
like there's some magical place where a
Snowmass like me could literally chill
out year round yes
Larry Snowman's Land what are we waiting
for let's go but getting to Snowman's
Land
may be harder than they think
[Music]
get ready for magic are we ready
[Music]
music hey you know what we need tones
say goodbye
[Music]
and a whole lot of cat and mouse
[Music]
get in the holiday spirit with a brand
new Tom and Jerry movie
Tom and Jerry Snowman's Land
[Music]